[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
Oh friends how about an amazing fact
don't let their saggy skin fool you
iguanas are remarkable reptiles found
mostly in the Caribbean islands as well
as Central and South America these big
lizards look like mini dinosaurs and
they seem to be at home up in trees in
the water or on land iguanas also come
in a rainbow of colors like blue green
orange brown purple your speckled skin
works like camouflage allowing them to
blend in with a local landscape the flap
of skin iguanas have below their neck is
called a du lob that helps them regulate
their body temperature and also to
display aggression presumably to other
iguanas on the top of their head sees
alien looking lizards even have a type
of third eye it's actually a retina
photoreceptor that helps them maintain
their circadian rhythms iguanas
generally live around water and are
excellent swimmers which of course is a
way for them to escape predators
amazingly they have the ability to
survive underwater for nearly half an
hour without breathing if they're caught
in a flood or washed out to sea during a
hurricane some species of iguana can
inflate themselves and float along in
the ocean until they find land when
attacked iguanas used their tail to slap
their enemy and as a last resort they
can even detach a part of their tail and
make a fast escape like other lizards
they'll eventually grow a new one
even though iguanas may look fierce
they're mostly vegetarians eating plants
fruits leaves an occasional bug but
because they're so docile they're often
kept as pets and they've been known to
live over 20 years
iguanas loved to climb and are generally
very stable in the trees on the
occasion when they lose their grip and
they slip it's incredible how tough they
are they can survive Falls from 40 or 50
feet without injury you know the Bible
says God can help us survive Falls as
well stay with his friends we're gonna
learn more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
thats one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastor doug batchelor welcome
listening friends to Bible answers live
my name is Doug Batchelor and our
regular co-host Pastor John Ross's he's
in the air somewhere between here in
India where amazing facts operates and
evangelism training school but by the
grace of God and with our crew here in
the studio we're gonna do our best to
answer your Bible questions that's what
the program is all about if you have a
Bible question pick up your phone we've
got about half of our lines open great
opportunity to get your question on
tonight's program let me give you the
number again 800 god says and that's an
acronym for eight hundred four six three
seventy to ninety seven four six three
seven two 97 starting with an eight
hundred and my name is Doug Batchelor
we're gonna start our program as we
always do with a word of Prayer
dear father we thank you for this new
day this new year of life that we have
and we invite your presence to be here
with us on this radio program and that
you'll give us guidance as we search
your word to better understand the truth
and your will we pray this in Jesus name
Amen
you know friends it was just a few weeks
ago that Karen and I were in Puerto Rico
doing some speaking and at one point we
found ourselves surrounded by iguanas
and they were amazing creatures they
were even climbing up two or three
storeys in the concrete above and around
the hotel and we saw them munching on
the grass outside very interesting
creatures they I remember when I was a
kid they take iguanas and put them in a
studio and they've glue some other
appendages to them and pretend that they
were aliens they videotaped them and and
make horror films out of these magnified
iguanas but they're actually pretty
docile creatures and so I did a little
research
and was amazed to find out all the
interesting things I could learn about
iguanas especially amazed me that how
tough they are they seem to survive
storms and and floods and Great Falls
you know sometimes we fall too and the
Bible tells us in the book of Jude that
if we slip and if we fall God is able to
keep us from falling and to present us
faultless by the way that's in Jude
verse 24 and 25 now unto him that is
able to keep you from falling and to
present you faultless before the
presence of his glory with exceeding joy
to the only wise God Our Saviour be
glory and Majesty Dominion and power
both now and forever amen he can keep
you from falling but when you do fall
what do you do the Bible tells us that
if we sin if we confess our sins he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness no matter how many times
you've fallen in the past friends God
can pick you up and help you get a new
beginning and the Bible tells us that
he's there to hold our hand and to give
us that fresh start we have a free offer
tonight we'd like to make available and
it's a lesson on how you can get that
new beginning
it's called rescue from above rescue
from above we'll send it to you for free
all you have to do is call and ask for
it now the resource number is a little
different than the studio question line
the resource phone is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
one more time if you'd like to get a
copy of rescue from above or maybe you'd
like to just have prayer with one of our
chaplains again that number eight
hundred eighty five six seven four seven
and with that we're gonna start going to
the phones and talk now with our first
caller who is Archie calling from Lodi
California listening on KFI a welcome
Archie you're on the air okay
[Music]
Hebrews and also in Leviticus without
blood being sprinkled on in the holy
place the most holy place on the part of
the daily sacrifice yeah that's a great
quest
that's a good question the first of all
the the reference you're talking about
when they sprinkled the blood the they
only did that one time when they
activated the sanctuary in the
wilderness in other words when they
first built it and they were you know
how they kind of christen a ship when
they first inaugurated the sanctuary for
use they sprinkled all the vessels in
the holy of holy place including the
there was a vessel that held the
writings of Moses those writings were
lost for a while and rediscovered during
the time of King joash but I was at
Josiah sorry but he was in a container
and they sprinkled it I'm sure they
didn't sprinkle it right on the
sheepskin or parchment that they had
written on but it is true that on a
yearly basis the high priest would go
into the Holy of Holies and sprinkle
blood and then on a daily basis there
were daily sacrifices where the priest
would go into the holy place and they'd
sprinkle blood principally on the horns
of the altar of incense
now I've always wondered that myself and
I've looked in the scripture for when
did they come in with a mop and a bucket
and clean that well you know evidently
the Levites and the Levites were given
the job of kind of maintaining the
sanctuary the sons of Aaron were the
priests the Levites were the extended
family of the children of Levi and they
would do the maintenance I'm guessing
that some of them went in on a regular
basis and they would just do basic
cleaning because the sprinkling of the
blood they knew it was a symbol and you
couldn't let that build up over hundreds
of years or you'd have a mess
or even the 40 years they were in the
wielding yeah well and I'm guessing that
if if they didn't do it on a weekly
basis they must have done it
during the feasts or at least Yom Kippur
which was called the cleansing of the
sanctuary now you said you had two
questions where did I answer in both her
what was the second no during that time
the sacrifices were required and closely
enforced under the theocracy they were
ended these days we have a foot washing
service and Jesus said do this in
remembrance of me all right another good
question you know it it tells us in the
Bible that for the for a Christian now
obviously we don't need to sacrifice
lambs because Jesus said I am the lamb
and Paul says Christ is our Passover but
the institutions that Jesus gave the
church are course baptism he tells us go
teach baptize it's very clear and then
what we call the Lord's Supper and that
included the the bread and the grape
juice symbols of his body and blood and
in John 13 he washed their feet and he
said that if I've washed your feet you
ought to wash one another's feet and so
in our church and I know in a number of
churches they still practice on either a
quarterly annual or biannual basis where
members get together and they'll wash
each other's feet and a number of
churches do this some don't do that some
just do the bread and the wine but Jesus
was pretty explicit there in John 13 he
said if I've washed your feet you ought
to wash one another's feet because I've
given you an example that you should do
as I've done great questions Archie and
I hope that helps a little bit and
appreciate your call we're gonna talk
next to Emma who's calling from
Louisiana listening on WN xB herma
you're on the air with Bible answers
live and how are you bet I'm doing well
appreciate your call yeah I'm calling
I'm concerned
I did hear where they said earlier that
babies will be resurrected in the
resurrection in you know in in place in
heaven with their parents but I was
concerned about the the aborted babies
how would that work for them well now
you know you're asking me something that
I'll do my best to answer but I need to
tell you and everyone listening right
now I'm doing this by permission not by
commandment in other words there are
some things that it's difficult to
answer and you just need to admit it my
it's my understanding that of course the
children of saved parents will be raised
whether they if any child died in
infancy and that may also be a premature
pregnancy will be in the resurrection
maybe there's a woman that made the
mistake of having an abortion and she
turned to Christ she might be she might
find that the angels will carry that
baby to her in the resurrection and
she'll get that baby I mean I don't know
there there is a statement in job and
the exact verse escapes me but I think
it's in like the first four chapters
where job said when he's crying about
his suffering he said I wish that I
could have been like a stillborn child
that went from the womb to the grave and
be as though I had not been now it's
almost sounds like there are some
stillborn children perhaps stillborn
children of the Lost that will be as
though they had not been they're
obviously not the guilty so they're not
gonna suffer for anything but I think
we've got to be careful about saying
that every conceived baby of everybody
saved or loss is all they're all going
to be in heaven now I got again I'm
being careful because I don't know all
things are possible with God but it
would almost seem like heaven is gonna
are you gonna be swimming in babies now
we know there's children in heaven
because it says the child will play on
the den of the venomous serpent and they
won't be hurt so in the resurrection
some children who died as children will
be raised as
or if their children when Jesus comes
they're caught up to meet the Lord in
the air
Malachi says they'll go forth and they
will grow up in the book of Zephaniah as
children will be plain and seen in the
streets and so there are children in
heaven I just I think we've got to be
careful about making a broad sweeping
statement one other reason I say that is
because in you find that in I think it's
1st Corinthians chapter 7 it talks about
how the children of believing parents
there's a sanctifying influence and it's
like when all the Lost died in the days
of Noah that we're outside the ark are
we assuming that every child of all the
loss will all be saved I don't know if
you can save it I don't think they're
gonna be punished because before the age
of accountability they're you know
they're not accountable anyway I hope
that helps a little bit Urmi it is a
tough question and I hope I didn't
offend anybody with my answer but I'm
just being honest thank you very much
for your call and we're gonna talk next
oh by the way that does open up a line
if you want to call with a Bible
question number once again 800 for six
three seven two nine seven 800 for six
three seven two nine seven brings your
question to me in the studio and they're
gonna talk next to Christopher listening
in the Carmichael California on K FIA
Christopher welcome you're on the air
good evening thank you Pastor Doug my
question for you is what does the Bible
say about attending a funeral on Sabbath
well you know the Bible doesn't really
address it specifically and I get this
question people say what about a wedding
you know isn't marriage sacred well some
are you know and the same thing with
some funerals I think that a funeral can
be a sacred occasion that would be in
harmony with things happening on the
Sabbath day where God could be glorified
and you know you get as much of the work
done ahead of time so it can still be a
day of rest I typically I discourage
people from planning their their
funerals or their weddings on the
Sabbath day because it often does
involve you know a lot of
work in preparation it can distract from
your worship experience I've been
weddings you know I know one couple that
they were gonna get baptized and then
they wanted to get married and they got
baptized and married on the Sabbath it
was you know very short service but it
was very sacred it was wonderful and
then I've been to weddings where you
know there's just drinking and dancing
and carrying on and you wouldn't want to
hit just inappropriate with worshiping
God you know what I'm saying so I think
that it varies I've been to some
memorial servants of saints and they
just the only day the family could come
together was the Sabbath and they do it
in the afternoon it was a sacred
occasion
so I don't know if that makes sense it's
the principle of you know are you
keeping the principle of the Sabbath
being holy and right and also a day of
rest you know anything that's getting
involved a lot of work and preparation
can be distracting and sometimes you
want to show your love and support for
that family and by all means you go okay
thank you very much all right Thank You
Christopher appreciate your question
moving on now talking with Marvin
calling from Ontario Canada Marvin
you're on the House Bible answers live
hello pastor Doug hi yeah
there's two scriptures that I'll just
give them to you and then I'll let you
explain them and one is Colossians 2:16
and the other one is glacials 328 all
right let's start with Colossians 2:16
if that's okay and what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna start by going back to 13
because I think that just gives you a
better context it says and being dead in
your sins and in the uncircumcision of
your flesh he is quickened together with
him having forgiven all your trespasses
blotting out the handwriting of
Ordinances that was against us the first
thing he's talking about blotting out
handwriting this is not the sum
people think this is the 10 commandments
being blotted out the ordinances were
written by Moses and it says against us
Paul here is referring to specific
language that is in Deuteronomy where
Moses said take the book of the law
place it in a pocket it was in a
compartment outside of the ark that it
may bear witness against you
it wasn't the Ten Commandments this
movies were the the ordinances and it
was written by the hand of Moses it
specifically says in the Bible these
were written by the hand of Moses and
that it's an end
there was the Ten Commandments they were
two separate things and within the
ceremonial laws and the ordinances were
a number of Sabbath's they were not the
weekly Sabbath of the Ten Commandments
because that goes back to creation in a
perfect world I mean right there in
Genesis chapter 2 you've got the first
Sabbath says blotting out the
handwriting of Ordinances that was
against us in contrary to us he took it
out of the way nailing it to his cross
he can't nail stone to anything having
spoiled principalities and powers he
made a show of them openly triumphing
over them in it here's the verse of
people wonder about let no man therefore
judge you in meat or in drink or in
respect of a holiday holiday or New Moon
or sabbath days and you'll notice it's
small s and it's plural these are the
annual Sabbath's like Yom Kippur Day of
Atonement Feast of trumpet they were
part of a law written by Moses on paper
the Ten Commandments were written by God
on stone the ceremonial laws spoken by
Moses Ten Commandments spoken by God so
the Sabbath day being blotted out here
our Sabbath days is the annual feasts
that's why Paul says in Romans chapter
14 you know one man regards one day
above another and other man regards
every day alike he's there talking about
the annual feasts so you know no pastor
tells his members you don't need to come
to church weekly anymore they don't use
this verse to say it's been nailed to
the cross and you don't need to worship
God on a weekly basis with with the
collective worship I'm talking about we
should worship God all the time but we
can't go to church all the time so they
only use this when people learn this
Sabbath truth they so know Sabbath been
nailed to the cross no it was the annual
Sabbath and your next verse I think you
said it was Galatians 3:28 so we're
gonna yeah okay we'll go there real
quick and I want to read that for listen
there's a lot of our folks are driving
down the road it says there is neither
Jew nor Greek there is neither bond nor
free there is neither male nor female
for you are all one in Christ Jesus
well back in the days of Paul many of
the Jews felt like they were in some way
superior to the Gentiles and that's why
you know Jesus and John the Baptist they
said do not think to say we are the
children of Abraham God is able to raise
up children of Abraham from the stones
and that the gospel was to go to all the
world not just to the Jews and Peter
said there is no what he call it
preferential treatment of persons with
God for he's made of one blood all
nations and so a very important lesson
was that in the days of the disciples
they said the Jews God gave them the
Oracles of truth but he doesn't love
Jesus more than other people he loves
everybody and the idea that perhaps you
were not as valid for salvation because
you were a woman or maybe you were
cursed because you were a slave Paula
sane everybody regardless of their
gender regardless of their race has
equal access to eternity because of
Jesus through the blood of Jesus right
and so you know God is not going to
discriminate based on whether a person
is rich or poor slave or free is your
Gentile male or female and so that's I
think the essence of what's happening
there in Galatians chapter around 3 hey
I appreciate your questions Marvin I
hope hope we got a happy customer and
that helped a little bit and I do have a
book I'll be happy to send you a free
copy and it's called spiritual Israel
spiritual Israel if you call the
resource line Marvin and it's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and tell them that the pastor Doug
said he's going to send you a free copy
of that book and you're listening to
Bible answers live with that opens up
another line if you have a question
that's 800
God says 800 for six three seven two
nine seven gonna talk next to Mel who's
calling from New Jersey listening to the
mission well welcome to the program
evening all likewise and your question
tonight okay talk about yeah Elijah the
Prophet when the children were mocking
and the Bears came out of the woods and
tour 42 of them know well the word tour
there is actually a particular word we
would use in modern English we'd say
mauled that means bit and scratched and
they may have been severely injured but
it it didn't kill them
it says the bear totally yeah and the
the these youth came out and because
Elijah had disappeared and evidently
Elijah who it was a servant their names
confuse people because ones he like JA
and one of the lice show Elijah went to
heaven and a fiery chariot Elisha was
his apprentice and they were saying go
up you bald head he must have been bald
and they're making fun of him and here
he is the principal prophet of Israel
and these kids are being disrespectful
and Elijah knew if he did not do
something at the beginning of his
ministry that no one would ever respect
him and he pronounced this curse and God
heard his prayer and these bears came
out and they they ran through these kids
there must've been quite a few of them
there because they were 42 they got
mauled and they went rip snortin through
those kids scratching and biting and
they never ever disrespected Elijah for
the you know he ministered for another
40 50 years and no one ever teased him
again you can be sure of that so it was
something that was a necessary lesson
[Music]
the second thing in Matthew 4:11 when
when the activity throughout the country
or the world predicted three wise men
coming to the manger where in Matthew 4
says they came to a house yes well but
most of the Hollywood and all have them
getting off their camels and bringing
myrrh and gold yeah you're you're very
perceptive because you're correct most
not all but most manger sings and
Christmas cards they show baby Jesus
with the shepherds in the manger and the
wise men all kneeling there together
biblically the Wiseman never saw the
Shepherd's after Joseph and Mary had the
baby they stayed in Bethlehem they had
family there they wanted her to gain
some strength before she began that
journey home and they also had probably
read the prophecies that the Messiah
came out of Bethlehem they weren't sure
if they were supposed to leave they were
waiting for a message from God and it
was months later if not over a year
later that the Wiseman finally showed up
because the wise men may have begun
their journey when it says they saw this
star that could have been the Angels
announcing to the Shepherd's so they
began the journey from the east we don't
know how far to the east they were but
you know probably took a while for them
to find out what does the star mean they
read there in the book of Balaam about a
star rising out of Jacob and they said
all this is a sign of the coming king
and they've got their gifts and they
made the journey their Shepherds had
been gone for maybe a year now the
reason I say that is when King Herod
asked about when the star appeared he
got the impression he should kill all
the baby boys two years old and younger
so Jesus was not an infant of a few days
or weeks old so you're right the the
wise man and the shepherds they never
saw each other but it makes for a good
manger scene in a good Christmas card
[Music]
even most helpful god bless you in your
ministry
thank you mail appreciate very much your
your call and again want to remind our
friends we do still have those three and
a half lines open and I say half a line
because we're gonna take a call here in
just a minute if you want to call in
with your Bible question once again the
number 800 god says that is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven we are alive if you got a
Bible question also don't forget we're
gonna take a quick break here
you can check out a lot more about
amazing facts by going to the website
amazing facts dot o-r-g we got gobs and
tons of plethora of information there
are Bible studies and videos and
archives of these programs and free
Bible study resources and videos and man
just makes my head swim to think about
it don't go away coming back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
through weld recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture Egyptians built pyramids to help
guide the spirits of their leaders Rome
sanctioned holidays to honor and appease
the spirits of their dead even the Bible
tells of a king that used a witch
to contact the spirit of a deceased
prophet today ancient folklore of
spirits and apparitions have gone from
mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
why do these stories persist does it
even matter we invite you to look inside
and find out for yourself visit death
truth dot-com every bible question you
have answered moves you one step closer
to the fullness of God's will for your
life so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live we still have a few
phone lines open if you have a Bible
related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
for more Bible answers live we're back
for Bible answers live and if you're
tuning in along the way this is a live
international interactive Bible study
and we invite you to participate you can
listen if you have a Bible question give
us a call if we don't get to you right
away hang in there we'll do our best to
get to your call the number eight
hundred four six three seven two ninety
seven my name is Doug Batchelor pastor
John Ross is on his way to India right
now doing some ministry there and I'm
gonna go talk to Joan who is listening
from Detroit Michigan Joan you're on the
air with Bible answers live you know in
the beginning was not anything made
right does that mean II created demons -
no let me see if I can explain it this
way we got bananas in the world but you
know God didn't make
bananas God made two Asian fruits and
then people buy cross pollinating those
two Asian fruits you get bananas that's
why you don't find any seeds in your
bananas you have never planted a banana
seat have you no all right so what
happened is it's a hybrid of something
God made beautiful angels and then one
of those angels named Lucifer rebelled
against God he was a beautiful good
angel
he ended up rebelling and he morphed he
transformed into it was an amalgamation
and he turned into Satan the devil he
did it by his own choice then he began
to campaign among some of the other
angels of God and many of them joined
Lucifer if you look in the book of
Revelation I don't know if you've got a
Bible at your fingertips there John no
well I'll read you the verse if you look
in Revelation chapter 12 it talks about
a war in heaven and Michael in his aim
that's verse 7 revelation 12:7 Michael
and his angels fought against the Dragon
and the dragon fought and his angels and
he didn't prevail but they were cast out
and the Dragon was cast out that old
serpent he was casting the earth his
angels were cast out with him these
fallen angels are better known now as
demons that's all that means they're
they're spirits that rebelled angels are
spiritual creatures and I will send you
a free lesson on this if you'd like it's
really great because it goes right along
with your question your question was did
God make a devil and the name of this
lesson is did God make a devil if you
call John our free resource number it's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven ask for the study guide did
God make a devil it's got beautiful
illustrations it's got all the bible
scriptures in there that makes it really
clear where the devil and where demons
came from matter of fact if you can get
online you don't even need to send for
the hard copy while you're welcome to do
that you can just go to amazing facts
dot o-r-g that's the amazing facts
website if you just google amazing facts
or type it into Yahoo I think it's the
first site
that pops up do a little search on did
God create a devil it'll take you to a
sermon a study guide it's a common
question and I think it's very important
thank you for your call Joan gonna talk
next with Sheila is calling from visit
dimple Texas Sheila Sheila you there hi
I gotta get we got about the background
noise and your question in the north
well it when he went to the Land of Nod
what it's telling us is he went to a
land that was now known or at least the
time Moses wrote that as nod but keen
took one of his sisters because if you
read in Genesis chapter five it says not
only did Adam and Eve have Cain Abel
Seth they also had many other sons and
daughters and only names the oldest ones
that kind of carried on the family name
but they had a lot of children Adam and
Eve lived over 900 years and you know
they probably had you know seven hundred
years of fertility back then I know it's
inconceivable to us today but the earth
was empty God told them be fruitful fill
the earth they had big families there
was nothing wrong with marrying your
sister in the beginning indeed Adam
married a girl that came from a rib so
you know God there's nothing wrong with
marrying your sisters in the early days
Abraham married Sarah who is his
half-sister Abraham and Sarah had the
same father and so Jacob married his
first cousin it wasn't until genetic
problems developed hundreds of years
later even thousands of years later it
was said in the time of Moses you
weren't supposed to be marrying your
close kin and so Cain married his sister
and they went and populated that area
that later was known as not and he built
a city and and as
hundreds of years went by and thousands
of people came I mean you look at
America we just in two hundred years not
counting the the Native Americans that
were here you just look now we got 300
million people here where you could have
walked for days and not found anybody on
the East Coast back in the early days so
hope that helps a little bit Sheila and
we appreciate your call and that does
free another line number again 800 god
says with your Bible question
okay who's been waiting patiently here
gonna talk next to Larry Larry calling
from somewhere I don't have the state
listen on XM radio okay satellite radio
and your question Larry I was wondering
about the when people get prayed for
yeah and sometimes I don't know they
they would fall over yeah and another
question also is when people dance on
the church and they try and use that for
biblical reference for when David danced
unto the Lord while he was bringing in
the ark into right and he's bring it
into Jerusalem from the house of
obed-edom yeah let's talk about that two
things one is and you've probably seen
on TV our friends listening have
probably seen on TV where in certain
churches they'll have people come
forward during a prayer session and the
pastor may lay hands on him he may
sometimes he pokes them sometimes they
blow on them they didn't do all kinds of
things and the people fall over and I
don't question their sincerity but I
just don't see that happening in the
Bible anywhere I don't see where Jesus
slap people on the head and they fell
over or where the disciples pushed no
more blue on them and they fell over for
prayer the only ones I saw falling over
were the enemies of Jesus when they came
to arrest Jesus and they asked who he
was he said I'm Jesus and when he said I
am they fell backward that was the
enemies so the idea that when God gives
us the Holy Spirit
all started falling down I don't see
that happening in the Bible I think
there was you know one time where King
Saul and this is in the first book of
Samuel
he was rebelling against the Lord and
the Holy Spirit came on him and he fell
down on the ground naked but he was kind
of fighting God at that time and that's
the only other case that you can even
come close to that so these services
where people are coming forward you find
that in a lot of pagan religions where
they kind of so overwhelmed with the
spirit they thrash and wallow around it
doesn't show that happening in the book
of Acts when the Holy Spirit was poured
out and so I do have personal issues
with that now the other question you're
asking about dancing there there is a
kind of dance that is appropriate it
tells you about when Miriam and she led
the women it wasn't notice it wasn't a
sexual dance it doesn't marry him
dancing with another man
Miriam and the women went out after the
Exodus and the sea opened up to save
them they sang songs of victory she
praise the Lord with tambourine it was
more like a folk dance of celebration it
wasn't the gyrating sexually suggestive
frenzies that people get into again when
David and Saul came back from a battle
victorious the women came out to sing
and to dance and to praise God for their
safe return this was a celebration
parade and that's appropriate in a
culture we do that in America you know
someone comes back from the moon and we
have a ticker tape parade and everyone's
clapping when David danced before the
Lord as they were transporting the Ark
again it was a celebration parade it
doesn't say that David was dancing in
church it saw it's a whole different
thing so I do have problems and I've got
friends that you know respectfully
disagree with me but and I've been to
churches where I'm in the service and
people seem overwhelmed with enthusiasm
and they start to kind of kick up their
heels and dance but I guess I come from
the belief that when you're in the
presence of God the Angels cover their
faces they cover their feet and they
they pray and cry holy holy holy
and the Bible says the Lord is in his
holy temple at all the earth be silent I
see a lot of scriptures and sums but
talk about reverence now it's okay to
praise the Lord and sing but I see it
being done reverently and the Lari if
you look in first Corinthians 14 Paul
said let all things be done decently in
an order
and if you read first Corinthians it
sounds like the Corinthian church things
were getting out of hand and he had to
tell them how to how to worship and how
to translate their sermons in an orderly
fashion and so yeah this is what I see
when I read the Bible it's a little
different than some of the popular
services you see yeah does that make
sense yes all right hey we really
appreciate your call and hope that helps
a little bit and with that we're gonna
try and squeeze in a few more callers
and talking next with Anthony who is
calling from Watertown New York
listening on the Internet Anthony you're
on the air with Bible answers live hi
pleasure speaking with you likewise I've
grown up always believing that there on
the second coming after the second
coming we will all go and then we'll be
there for the millennium and then the
Holy City will come back down after
they're at this Klan or and then they're
at this claim and so forth
however III don't know what to say to
someone who is searching or questioning
whether we truly do go up to heaven all
the scriptures I see even 1st
Thessalonians 4 verse 17 it says we'll
be caught up in the air to meet the Lord
in the air and then we'll be with him
forever but I can't really find any
scriptures that explicitly say we all go
to heaven well let me try and help a
little bit and there may not be a
scripture that explicitly says it but
there are some pretty good implications
if you look for instance in John 14 you
know the verse where Jesus said in my
father's house are many mansions if it
were not so I would have told you I go
to prepare a place for you and if I go
and prepare a place for you I will come
again
and receive you to myself that where I
am it's understood where was he's in the
father's house the Bible says the father
is in paradise when we pray we say our
Father we're in heaven says that where I
am you might be also so he says I'm
gonna come again and take you to my
father's house right John 14 so that's
one verse there and you know the Bible
tells us in Matthew he'll send his
angels to gather together his elect he's
coming in the clouds of heaven he's
coming in the glory of the Father well
where is he taking us he's probably not
going in on Star Trek journeys taking us
back to heaven and then when you read in
John chapter 21 the New Jerusalem comes
down from God out of heaven and the
Saints are in the city how could we come
out of heaven if we haven't first gone
into heaven so you're correct if you
know you're saying there's no verse that
it explicitly says that but there's a
lot of pretty basic references that
leave you no other conclusion so yeah
when you know we've got two destinies
we've got God is gonna create a new
earth and that's obviously after the
planet has been purified by the fire it
talks about the wicked will be destroyed
by the brightness of his coming the
elements will melt with fervent heat the
earth and the things and it will be
burned up that's the second Peter
chapter 3 then we're caught up we're not
being burned up we're caught up before
that happens
it says I take you back to the place I
prepared then at the end of the 1,000
years the New Jerusalem comes down from
God out of heaven so that's actually one
place in Revelation where things are
written chronologically you've got the
1,000 years in Revelation 20 you've got
the New Jerusalem coming down in
Revelation 21 and then you've got the
destruction of the wicked in revelation
22 so does that help a little yes
especially revelation 21 where he said
we're coming back the Holy See is coming
out of heaven and we're in the holy city
we you know how can we be coming you
know with but
that makes and then of course in
Revelation 20 it says that you know
after the Lord comes it says we live and
reign with him for a thousand years now
if the condition of the earth and this
is another example Bible says the earth
is desolate after the second coming from
Jeremiah chapter 4 says the earth is
desolate the cities are broken down
there is no man Isaiah says I will make
the earth utterly empty jeremiah says
the slain of the lord will be from one
end of the earth to the other with no
one to lament mourn or bury them it
describes a condition of the world where
there's nobody alive on the planet and
so we're definitely not here so you know
what I'd like to do is I've got a lesson
I'll send you a free copy that has all
these references in it and it's talking
about a thousand years of peace a
thousand years of peace if you call 808
three five six seven four seven we'll
send you a free copy of a thousand years
of peace you could even just type in
anthony i'm go to the amazing facts
website type in doug batchelor
millennium you can probably type that
into youtube and you'll see my messages
on this where I give all the references
appreciate your call and with that we're
gonna talk next to Robert listening on
line five but you didn't know you were
on line five college place Washington
Robert you're on the air thank you for
taking my call thank you for calling and
no problem I was calling because I've
heard or experienced to contradict a
contradiction with Galatians 5:18 if you
are led by the spirit you are not under
the law but in Romans chapter eight
verses seven they seem to say that we if
a person is led by the Holy Spirit they
well that is a good question a lot of
people have wondered about that one of
the keys is what does it mean to be
under the law some people have thought
under the law means are we under an
obligation to obey the law well let's
talk about that for just a second
if under the law means you're under an
obligation to obey the law and not under
the law means you don't have to obey the
law what would it mean if Christians
were being told you don't have to obey
the law you don't have to it's okay to
lie it's okay to steal it's okay to
commit adultery kill use God's name in
vain
of course everyone knows that's absurd
but if under the law means under the
penalty of the law see when you disobey
you are under the judgment or penalty of
the law when we are forgiven we are no
longer under the penalty of the law we
are now under grace we've been forgiven
that doesn't mean we stop obeying it
means now we don't have the condemnation
we don't have the guilt we don't have
the shame if we're spirit-led we know
that we've been saved from the penalty
of the law if we're being led by the
spirit and not the flesh if you're led
by the flesh you're committing adultery
and doing those other things you're led
by the spirit you're not because the
spirit you know Paul says the the fruit
of the Spirit is love joy peace and if
you love your neighbor you're not gonna
kill them love is the fulfilling of the
law you love God you're not gonna use
his name in vain you see what I'm saying
and so when you love God and when you
love your neighbor you will keep the Ten
Commandments because love is the
fulfilling of the law all the law and
the prophets is summarized in love but
basically saying the same thing and Paul
is in Romans chapter 8 where it says
therefore no no condemnation to those
who are in Christ Jesus who walk not
according to the flesh but according to
the spirit not walking according to the
flesh means you're not living that
lawless life of the lost you're now
being led by the spirit and that means
you're walking in the will of God
yes as I sing in verse verse 7 carnal
mind is enmity against God not subject
to law God neither indeed can be right
when were were controlled by the flesh
the carnal mind is totally opposed to
the law of God but when we're filled
with the spirit and love we delight to
do the things of God
you know there's a lesson I'll send you
a free copy that specifically talks
about your question and it's called does
God's grace blot out his law does God's
grace blot out his law and if you call
the resource line 808 three five six
seven four seven now the line to the
studio is 800 God says it's different
but our resource line and we have
chaplains standing by that line if you
have a prayer request also 808 three
five six seven four seven ask for that
book does God's grace blot out the law
this asks for the book on law and grace
and they'll know what that is thank you
Robert appreciate your call and talking
next with bill who's calling from
Champaign Illinois bill you're on the
air with Bible answers live I thank you
for taking my call my question is this
it's a pretty fundamental question once
a person has accepted Jesus Christ as
their personal Lord and Savior can they
lose their salvation I guess that comes
under the rubric of one saved always
saved okay good question you ready for
me to try and answer that it's a
two-fold question in order for a person
to be lost salvation is a it's a
covenant there's two parties in the
Covenant there's you and God God has
done his part to save we must accept by
faith his part God will never go back on
his part but the question is do we lose
the freedom to forfeit or go back on our
part and I see in the Bible that there
are examples of people who said yes I'll
follow Jesus but then they turned away
and you've got you know the children of
Israel who followed him out of Egypt but
then they died in the wilderness because
they lost faith not all of them but many
did
you've got Judas who Jesus sent out
along with the twelve casting out Devils
and working miracles and but he wouldn't
give up his
his covetousness and he lost that Peter
talks about the person who is like the
dog that returns to his vomit or the pig
that has washed who returns to wallowing
in the mire Paul says over and over if
you continue in these things there's a
continuing that goes on because
salvation Paul said I die in daily daily
we've got to say no to self jesus said
except you take up your cross daily and
follow me so being a Christian the idea
that once you say that you're gonna
follow the Lord that there's no longer
effort involved in nurturing that
relationship you can just kind of throw
your your desires to the wind and say
well I accept the Jesus I was saved I
can do whatever I want I can't be lost
now that's reckless so it is something
that needs to be nurtured it needs to be
maintained and I've got a book I'll send
you for free and it's specifically Billy
answers your question it's called can a
slate saved man be lost
isn't that pretty much what you're
asking yeah
in Judas's case so Jesus had not yet
died for his sins and I I have a little
trouble theoretically of course a person
could just say oh I'm not interested aim
where but I don't have any specific amp
examples myself in Scripture well you
you do have examples where Paul said
there there was a follower named Dimas
and he was a follower of God and he was
an associate of Paul's and then later in
one of Paul's letters he says demas has
forsaken me having loved the present
world and it looks like Dimas threw in
the towel and gave up his faith and so I
you know I don't believe and and you got
to be very careful does that mean that
once you've given your heart to the Lord
if you sin you slip and you fall and you
sin that God has cast you off and you've
lost your relationship no I think that
being a Christian is like in marriage it
doesn't mean they'll have no
disagreements in marriage but you've
made a covenant you love each other and
as long as you stick together
you're gonna maintain that covenant
in in our relationship with the Lord we
may fail him sometimes but he will never
fail us and we don't need to worry about
that so you can have assurance as a
Christian but I also think it's
dangerous to be reckless and to say oh
well you know I've been saved and so I
don't have to you know resist temptation
I don't have to try to follow the Lord
and obey Him and and struggle against
strive and struggle in war against the
flesh if you're Christian there are
battles involved now I'll send you that
book and bill it's called can a saved
man be lost please call 808 three five
six seven four seven and they'll just
telling you're listening to Bible
answers live they'll send that to you by
the way you can listen to that book or
read that book right now for free you
don't have to wait for us to mail it if
you want to read it online you go to the
amazing facts free book library and that
is one of the books there because we get
that question quite a bit is once a
person saved can they be lost do they
lose their freedom of choice can they
save man be lost we'll be happy to send
that to you and so we we appreciate your
question on that bill listening friends
you know I'm looking at the clock and
our engineer tells us I've just got a
minute and I think it might be an insult
to try to squeeze a commercial or
squeeze a a question into the short time
we have before we have a commercial
break right now so if you'll give us a
chance try to call again next time and I
want to remind you some of you may want
to you don't just you got a new year you
say I want to know the Lord better this
year not too late for that resolution
we're only one week into the new year if
you go to the website Bible Universe
Bible universe calm Bible universe dot
o-r-g either one will take you there
there's a great series of Bible study
resources you can say I'm going to begin
the year I'm going to start reading
through the Bible and I am going to do a
serious Bible study program and it takes
you through a set of 27 Bible studies
that will just change your life and
bless your heart I can promise you trust
me friends you go through the amazing
Bible study course you will never be the
same it'll give you an understanding of
God in the Bible and who he is and his
will for your life
and you'll understand something about
the times in which we're living and that
Jesus is coming soon most importantly
it'll tell you about how to get ready so
just go check out Bible Universe calm
now people do a lot of their giving in
December and there's a lot of lovely
Appeals and folks make generous
tax-deductible gifts here we are in
January and our ministry has not stopped
it goes on 365 days a year every week
every day amazing facts is ministering
around the world if you want to help us
stay on this station and do more just
donate online amazing back to our G god
bless
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include bible essence
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF as a RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions